уже рік як минулі події в Ірпені рівно
рік тому Ось на цій вулиці точилися бої
сюди бачите перелітало настільки
серйозно що на цій ірпінській вулиці
вона і мені боїлась а не залишилося
фактично жодного цього будинку і досі
Ірпінь дуже багато будівель перебувають
в тому ж самому стані що рік тому і
багато родин
сьогодні живуть у тимчасових будинках
які надані були
іноземними державами в якості
гуманітарної допомоги і
їм важко було переживати цю зиму коли не
було світла
генератори зараз підуть до багатодітних
родин в Ірпіні і Буча і родини які
найбільше потребують і найбільше
постраждали від відсутності електрики
протягом тривалих блокаутів і Хоч зараз
ситуація уже покращується потроху з
електроенергії але ніхто не гарантує що
нові відключення і тривалі можуть бути і
в майбутньому генератори від фонду
теофіпольське серце такі очолює наша
колега
голова фракції європейського
солідарності у ірпінській міській раді
Наталії здебська і вона
надає постійно допомогу своєму рідному
місту Ірпінь Буча тримайте
для дітей двоє дітей 5 років у вас
скільки тут живе щас четверо поки
плануєте відбудовувати будинок Ну якщо
будемо можливості що буду допомагати
волонтери бо без них щас це віддавати
такий будинок невозможностих
Як життя
багато двоєк на хапали ні
Ну слава Богу головне треба вчитися
добре
щасливо ось будинок Подивіться посічені
уламками
ворота розбитий будинок фактично Тут
живе скільки у вас
четверо тут родина Яка фактично живе без
власного розбитому будинку
користуйтеся на здоров'я
допомога Да він ну трохи важить трохи є
ще є що нести так що тримайте далі
європейська Солідарність зокрема депутат
ірпінської міськради Наталія іздевська
вона мені хороший друг її фонд
теофіпольське серце ми всі разом зараз
організували доставку до Ірпеня Бучі 12
генераторів для
багатодітних сімей тобто Ті хто
опинилися найбільш вразливими у часи
блекауту і
найбільшу кількість
генераторів отримають саме ті
багатодітні сім'ї чиї будівлі були
зруйновані рік тому